all of our executive education programs
are highly immersive and engaging online
educational experiences for
executives not only did i learn really
really valuable content i also made some
amazing connections with people who
are wickedly smart but also incredibly
passionate as well as humble we have a
network
of highly committed faculty and learners
who are
engaged in teaching each other and
learning from one another
and this has been truly remarkable
probably done five or six different
executive education programs it's some
of the
best business schools in the country but
this was my first
at stanford and both the quality
of the instruction the quality of the
classmates
but then also how well stanford has
leveraged
technology to really create an almost
in-classroom-like experience in terms of
your ability to
ingest the information but also the the
opportunity to build lasting
relationships with your classmates
to teach so many people from so many
different countries
from so many different industries to
learn from one another
is um a really remarkable experience
this group of people they're able to
take the learnings they're able to take
the content and apply it
immediately it exceeded my expectation
it was so
well curated that it really
felt like we were in class in all of our
executive education programs
the faculty who teach are those that are
research active and at the top of their
respective fields
so what that means for the participant
is that they're getting
the most recent research the most
cutting-edge research
delivered by the people who are
conducting that research delivering
uh this experience online i think you
know they pretty much nailed it
cases that you expect you know from
stanford to read and to reflect on
coupled with you know the professors
with you know great interactive
materials
and this basically connection with the
students
and virtual breakout rooms and all that
well facilitated in a platform that we
could reach easily every day
very very impressive how it was done
it's highly interactive it's highly
immersive and really does require
a lot of engagement and that's what
makes it work
i never imagined the program could be as
impactful as it was
through a remote learning process if
anyone wants a taste of stanford this is
an
excellent opportunity
you